بالفعل لعبت زوجاته اللاعبين دورا كبيرا
في حياتهم القصص كثيره ولعل احداثها حول
التاثير الكبير زوجه ليونيل ميسي التي
اصبحت حديثه الساعه بسبب الكلام عن رغبتها
في العوده الى برشلونه زوجه مارو ايكاردي
لاعب غلطه سرايا التركي حاليا وباريس سان
جيرمان السابق كان لها دور سلبي في
انتقالاته الكثيره ليفقد اللاعب مكانته في
المنتخب الارجنتيني فضلا عن فقدانه لبريقه
بعد تركه لانتر ميلان ايضا اللبنانيه
الاصل دانيلا سمعان كانت احدى اهم اسباب
انتقال زوجها نجم الكره الاسباني
الى برشلونه من ارسنال في صيف 2011 لتكون
قريبه من صديقتها زوجه ميسي وساهم الحب
الذي عاشه لاعب مانشستر سيتي السابق
وبرشلونه الحالي فيران توريس بانتقاله من
انجلترا الى اس بسبب رغبته بالبقاء قرب
حبيبته سيرا مارتينيز لينفصل قبل ايام فقط
بسبب عدم رغبتها بالرحيل عن برشلونه وهو
ايضا المهدد بالبيع من قبل النادي
الاسباني لضرورات ماليه ورياضيه واخيرا
وليس اخيرا تبدو بلارا روبيو زوجه المدافع
الاسباني سيرجيو راموس احدى المؤثرين
المباشرين في مستقبله القادم خصوصا بعد
تصريحاتها الاخيره حول مستقبله المجهول
ورغبتها في المشاركه في القرار النهائي
لحسمه
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات